somehow like literally like a piece of  software melded together fused and then  like it started to turn itself into like  a living breathing you know like a steak  with a brain like your meat that grew up  inside your mother you're like a wet  wear android and now you're like  grasping all this amazing information as  you map and model the world you're  growing you're learning you're expanding  you're slowly emerging as a thinking  being and it's like oh my god this is  what it's like to be a mind i mean  you're you're transcended  you're transcendent  you're transcendent but you're also like  made of flesh so it's like holding you  is like  what is this like actual piece of divine  miracle that somehow this universe  allowed to  organize  it's insane like looking into your eyes  actually feels like looking at a galaxy